we've been taught speaking of socialism
by the way we've been talking about not
only the debate that exists between
socialism and social democracy on the
program I've also been making it a point
to talk about the confusion between the
two because there is a lot of confusion
going on right now particularly over the
last six to twelve months about
socialism and democratic socialism as
compared to social democracy and this is
I want to be really clear this is not
today I'm not talking about which is
better okay look I've already said I'm a
social democrat
that's not today's story today's story
is just what are people actually saying
when they say they are one or the other
and is that accurate
we have those comparison clips you can
find them on YouTube debates
you know long-form investigations okay
that's not what this is this is just
about the fact that every time that I
explain that democratic socialism is
socialism and it includes a public
seizure of the means of production now
by seizure it doesn't necessarily mean a
violent seizure but it means a public
takeover a socialization of the means of
production and on the other hand social
democracy is highly regulated capitalism
with guarantees of certain social
welfare benefits as a right there are
people who tell me David that's
semantics you're making a semantic
distinction that's not an important one
just because something is a confusion in
language doesn't mean that we can write
it off as merely a semantic dispute
socialism is socialism it's a total
appending of the system that we have
sometimes by revolution sometimes by
extreme means although at least as it's
hypothesized in socialist literature it
doesn't necessarily have to be that way
social democracy is fixing capitalism so
that it works okay I am thrilled that
economist Paul Krugman wrote about this
exact confusion a few days ago in the
New York Times and he makes a few
different really good points leading up
to the part about the confusion between
social democracy and democratic
socialism and I want to take a look at a
couple of them with you because he says
far better than I could where some of
this confusion is and he argues first of
all that the rise of people calling
themselves socialists isn't surprising
because of the acute failings of our
capitalist system so let's go to the
first quote from the article Krugman
writes this rise was predictable and
predicted here's what happened for
decades the right has tried to shout
down any attempt to sand down some of
the rough edges of capitalism whether
through health guarantees income
supports or anything else by yelling
socialism sooner or later people were
bound to say that if any attempt to make
our system less harsh is socialism well
they're socialists this is a really good
point when the left over the last 10 20
30 years has proposed socially
democratic reforms looking at guarantees
of health care higher minimum wages
reducing income inequality these are not
socialist ideas they are ideas of social
democracy the right has responded by
saying you socialists suggesting that
and what has that led to it has
partially led to people thinking well if
that's socialism then I guess I'm a
socialist and of course the capitalist
system also has led to arise in both
socialist thinking and socially
democratic thinking so so far Krugman is
spot on then we get to the key part and
this is exactly what I've been saying
he writes quote the truth is that there
are hardly any people in the United
States who want the government to seize
the means of production or even the
economy's commanding Heights what they
want is social democracy the kinds of
basic guarantees of health care
protection against poverty etc that
almost every other advanced country
provides this is not a criticism of
socialism I said it at the beginning and
I want to say it again if you are
actually a socialist with peace and love
let's debate socialism versus social
democracy and let's have that
conversation
what Krugman is pointing out is that a
lot of the people saying they're
socialists just aren't socialists
this is not semantics we often talk
about Sweden as a social democracy
Krugman talks in his article about
Denmark which he says his quote arguably
the most social democratic country in
the world tax revenues make up 46
percent of GDP in Denmark they have
a very high labor force participation
rate the right claims to care about that
figure they work shorter hours than in
the United States life satisfaction is
higher than in the United States and yes
GDP per capita is lower in Denmark but
it's not affecting quality of life and
it's not affecting life satisfaction or
educational outcomes or health outcomes
so to go back now to the social
democracy versus democratic social
socialism confusion if you want to argue
as some of you do that in 2018 DSA
democratic socialists of America is a
big tent and welcomes everybody buddy
whether or not they are actually
socialist whether or not they want to
socialize the means of production that's
a practical argument that we can have
nobody benefits from people thinking
that what they want is socialism when in
reality they want guaranteed government
health care and a living wage education
paid through taxes and a stronger social
safety net is Paul Krugman write about
everything all the time
no he actually had some really unfair
criticisms of Bernie back during 2016
but he's right about this and I am going
to implore everybody in our audience if
you get an opportunity in conversation
to clarify the confusion between social
democracy and socialism take that and do
it clarify that confusion because I
think it's important yeah I mean that's
the best path forward especially because
the word socialism has been demonized so
much by the right that there's no really
no coming back from it at this point so
if you're not a socialist don't call
yourself a socialist you're just giving
the right-wing ammunition against you
maybe well there's there's a number of
polls that show that actually
socialism has come back in other words
approval of socialism has skyrocketed
relative to where it's been and I think
part of it is again because of what I
described at the beginning of the story
which is because the right has been
calling social democracy democratic
ideas socialists for so long people are
saying oh well if that socialism than it
is a good thing so I think the opposite
which is socialism has had a resurgence
in popularity I just think a lot of the
people who claim to be socialist aren't
actually and this is third time I'm
saying it it's not an argument for or
against socialism it's an argument that
when we talk about economics we should
know what we're talking about and I'm
Paul Krugman wrote about it send me your
thoughts you can always discuss this on
our subreddit or also you can comment on
the David Pakman show
Instagram yeah behind-the-scenes
pictures and so much more we are david
pakman show on instagram follow us there
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinkie's is
a great service that i use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and i've
listened to a ton of books on blinka
cently checked out
soccer na mcc's by simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on blinka they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink is calm slash Pakman
if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa k mas